let's talk about why they're freaking
out though from the pittsburgh post
gazette elon musk says that he would
reverse twitter's ban of donald trump
let me just spell this out
it is expected in three months
twitter will be owned wholly by elon
musk
and he will unban donald trump that
means
whether trump intends to use the
platform or not he will be on the
platform the account will exist it will
be verified it will have followers all
the tweets will be there when the ban is
lifted
i think you know trump uh trump will use
it trump said before he's gonna stay on
truth social don't believe it i mean
he'll probably stay on it he'll probably
use truth but he's gonna be on twitter
and he's gonna be tweeting absolutely
and the reason this freaks them out so
much like you mentioned just a moment
ago with the fact checkers they need as
much control over the narrative as
possible and what trump did
it used to be that journalists would get
the statement from the politician and
then choose how to report it
and if you were a politician
and you said something like
we'll play the game you'll be talking to
a reporter and you'll be like i had one
guy come up to me and say i don't like
i don't like eating cheeseburgers
and uh i thought it was a crazy thing to
hear then the news newspaper article
quote i don't like cheeseburgers says
politician and the only thing you can do
is say they're lying it's not true and
how do you prove it with donald trump on
twitter he would just tweet
cheeseburgers are delicious it's fake
news and then people would be like okay
well trump just said it he bypassed the
narrative control the narrative machine
so he'll have to come back remember one
time he actually posted the full video
of an interview he did that he said was
going to be selectively edited so he
just released the entire interview
before they could get the ratings from
it what was that it was an abc news
interview yeah well he just actually
stall yeah it was i think it was the
leslie stallman he's like yeah by the
way we recorded the whole thing here's
the audio here's the video here's morgan
just manipulated video to make it seem
like trump got angry and stormed off did
you see that dude it's all it's all just
lies man since the beginning baby yeah
yeah
that's part of why
i'm very surprised when anyone does sit
down with these interviewers especially
people on the right i can't imagine
doing something like that unless you'd
recorded it or were recording it and
have the right to release the footage
and sort of discuss that with them it's
insane to allow them to to filter you
yeah you got to have access to the media
like a direct line the technology's
available you've got to use it as a
politician in general i don't like these
things when the when they give emergency
beep warnings you guys hear that on the
audio yeah can you hear it this phone's
violated that's mine it's yours i feel
violated by that it's definitely mine
yeah my child abduction alert
i didn't sign up for this
if you are in maryland the maryland
state police the request of the carroll
county sheriffs have issued an amber
alert for nine-year-old savannah rosetta
nicole heaton a white female the child
clothing description is unknown the
child was last observed at approximately
6 p.m in the westminster area of carroll
county the child me may also be in the
baltimore area
well thank you
for pointing that out that helps a lot
of people well exactly i figured if
we're getting the alert right now and
there's somebody in the area we just
blasted that message out there hopefully
it helps yeah i don't want these creepos
again these kids
okay all right well anyway what were we
talking about the importance of media
going around you were saying people need
to have access to
people to be able to get out yes and it
should not be mandated but like how long
should a politician have to listen to
people every day two hours i don't know
but in order to clarify what people say
about you you've got to have vocal
access to masses unfettered well that's
why shows like those shows like rogan
are such a threat to journalists and you
really saw this with the coordinated
assault on joe rogan in particular
because he is the most listened to
person
in the northern hemisphere right
his show was displaced recently from the
number one spock yeah batman beat him
yeah batman beat him
but it's the batman podcaster one yeah
it's a batman podcast oh my god it's
like a weird batman podcast which which
batman is it or is it a robert pattinson
the lego batman
i don't know sheamus which batman is oh
i have no idea why would i know i don't
know because you sounded like you knew
this psychology you look the most like
robert pattinson of anyone in this oh my
gosh how dare you
it's called batman the audio adventures
oh my god scripted podcast from dc
entertainment hey that sounds fun a lot
of zealots out there wait until they
pull out bruce wayne's old tweets and
they'll just
i mean you're driving in your car and
you want to listen to something
yeah but not joe rogan
batman's but wait until batman becomes a
threat to the establishment exactly
batman's just like vote for trump i'm
pretty sure batman was a threat to the
establishment exactly but not right now
i mean look they're letting him be
number one on spotify no batman wasn't a
threat to the establishment he would go
up on the roof of the police building
and collude with the police and
everything some of the police look
that's back when the police were uh you
know doing their job probably i think
they were crooked some of them not the
ones he was talking to he made what
happened to harvey dent in the dark
knight
gordon was awesome though yeah he was a
good to this day
gordon what's his name is that his first
name jim gordon jim gord jim gordon
elon musk is not like batman he's like
iron man he's like iron man which brings
us back to elon musk
taking control of twitter i can't wait
for all the brilliant think pieces about
what a threat it is to democracy to
allow donald trump on twitter i can't
wait for them to light up their biden
given crack pipes that's why i was
saying before
the system has crumbled and collapsed
already it's fake outrage it's the
weirdest thing
when
you you know what i'm gonna stop right
there it's simple
if you are on the right
you know
the left's arguments you've engaged with
them if you are on the left
most likely you have not heard the
right-wing argument and you have not
engaged with i would tell you i think
what they think the right-wing argument
is is that and this i don't want to deal
the conversation in religion but it's
that
jesus's mother got impregnated by a
ghost they're like do these yeah you're
putting it in an intentionally way
exactly this is what they think they
tell people that you and other people
are on the right side i believe you're
telling me what i think this is what's
happening
this is how they view the right is that
they believe that a girl got impregnated
by a spirit and so how can we take that
seriously how can i take that seriously
it's it's it's because you think that
you so you think
a belief that mary was impregnated via
the holy spirit is why the left doesn't
like the right and i understand that
part of the dis
dismissal love the argument i think ian
i understand what you're trying to say
but i think you're being actually too um
what's the right
you're being you're giving them do you
bring too generous
the left wouldn't say mary was
impregnated by a ghost they would say
the right is about are a bunch of bronze
age crackpots who believe in old
fictional it starts with i just picked
that as one thing that i'm like what
okay let's talk about it but it spirals
into like oh and then they're crazy
about this and this is this and this
you're definitely wrong ian because they
don't they would also say that men can
get pregnant so you know a woman got
pregnant you'd be a birthing person you
know all of these sorts of things it
does bring up abortion topic about
abortion and holy conception there's a
meme
and it says
my religion says i can't do this so i
won't and they say that's good for you
and they say my religion says you can't
do this and they say f off and that's
the argument they've been using for roe
v wade because they've never actually
asked a pro-lifer what's their position
they then say on twitter republicans are
engaged in fake outrage
i look at that and i'm like it's really
weird because
you know we talked to so many people on
the right on this show we've heard their
arguments articulated we've heard the
left articulate their arguments but
their arguments are based on not knowing
what the rights arguments are and they
don't come on the show
shout out to daryl davis who we had on
the show a lot of people were not happy
with things he had to say but he did say
something very important he was invited
to a dinner
with the far right and the far left
whatever that means and he said you know
clan members and nazis all showed up
and then when he got to this dinner to
have a conversation he was the only
person from the left who showed up
they don't engage they don't know what
the right things they're not arguing
anything i think oh i think it's a type
of dismissal like they don't they don't
take it seriously because of the
religion stuff
no no i think that's what it is i'm
trying i mean i'm trying to figure out
like everybody else but no they they say
don't platform don't you legitimize it i
i think the real issue is i was in um
what was i in san bernardino there's a
protest trump supporters were protesting
so antifa shows up
i walk over to the leftist side where
they're all protesting and i saw people
standing around and i walked over and
was like i was like how's it going guys
then all of a sudden someone yells mike
check and then the entire group goes mic
check and they go do not do not everyone
repeats it talk to talk to anyone anyone
they will try they will try to confuse
you
to confuse you and then i was like
does anybody want to tell me what's a
mic check mike check mike check my and
then they chant for about 30 seconds to
a minute i'm like okay and i walk off
i'm not exaggerating they did it they
did this at occupy wall street it is a
tactic of leftist organizers to prevent
the regular people there from hearing
anything someone might have to say no
that's a mob mobs for sure are near
impossible to communicate with of any of
any mindset but if you just get a
one-on-one conversation with two people
one from the left and one from the right
i think that if you come to a middle
ground it might have the religion might
be part of it i i certainly think so for
some people
that they don't understand but the core
is
they don't understand
so i was in berkeley after one of the
big protests
and i was standing on a street corner
filming and i was talking to some guy
when a leftist woman came up and started
pushing back on the things that were
being said
so i turn around holding my camera
and she started saying things and i was
like a woman
was shoved off she was standing like two
feet off the ground on a light post
standing on like the base of it and
someone shoved her and she fell down hit
her head and got blood everywhere
and she was like yeah well she shouldn't
have shown up here and then i was like
you think she shouldn't have allowed to
be here she's like she's a trump
supporter and she knew coming here would
get her attacked and then i was like
really so do you think if like a woman
wore provocative clothing and was
walking down this alley and she got
attacked by some guy because the way she
looked that's her fault too and she was
like
yeah i think so
and then i was like okay
and then after i was like well thank you
and have a nice day she walks away and
about a minute later she comes back and
says delete that footage delete it and i
was like i'm standing on a public street
and you talk to me i'm going to use it
now i'm not i don't try to dox people
anything so i blurred her face because
the idea is what is what's most
important i don't need people going to
this random woman who's talking on the
street the point was when this woman
from the protest was by herself and
decided to speak up she had no idea what
her positions were and she actually
agreed with blaming women who get
assaulted for the way they dress if the
video is on my my tim cass channel
somewhere you can find it um that's the
gist of the conversation
i think when you go to these protests
having been too many of them these
people don't know anything
i'll tell you my favorite
my favorite was antica pizza lista
during occupy wall street when they
would go ah auntie antica pizza
and then i saw a guy and he was going ba
abira nida bitsto
and i was like hey what are you chanting
i was like oh
i just you know
i'm like you don't know what you're
saying nobody knew what was being
chanted except for the organizers so
when they're screaming anti-capitalist
and these other people who just showed
up because they saw it on social media
or the news and they're just muttering
and mumbling
that's my experience with these protests
it's a religion it's like they're going
to church and and just trying to follow
guys teachings without knowing what he's
saying so they're just
i i think that's unfair
because having also been to churches the
people have books where they can reach
churches
that's for sure i developed this theory
when i was in college
i went to the university of chicago
where bernie sanders went and there's a
famous picture of him
getting arrested
protesting uh as a college student he
looks exactly the same as he does now
and uh he was protesting the school had
segregated housing and so he was
arrested protesting this and that's a
good thing to protest now the problem is
for students who are there now there's
nothing on that level of things to
protest about but they still want to get
that photo of them being arrested so the
president of the university of chicago
the student president when i was there
one year he chained himself to a
building in downtown chicago because he
was demanding right after trump won he
was demanding that our democratic
senators dick durbin and tammy duckworth
vote against the confirmation of betsy
devos for education secretary which they
did and they were always going to do he
got arrested he got the photo he
literally looks like a limp noodle so
it's not like you know bernie was
looking resolute this guy looks totally
pathetic he gets arrested held overnight
and then i hear him the next day telling
his leftist activist friends about this
and i said to him oh this sounds a lot
like white privilege you just got
arrested and just completely back out on
the street next week and the next day
and he said
no no no no it's not i mean it was every
activist wants that you know the left is
all about instagram that's all they care
about is getting that instagram story
the instagram infographic so being there
in that protest is what matters not
actually what they're saying so i
remember um
we talk about the algorithmic problem on
youtube where hitler was doing tai chi
with the incredible hulk because people
were just trying to find ways to make
viral content
because of politics
the virality of it because of coven
because of politics as pop culture
we are now seeing young people
claiming to be strategists or involved
in politics because they know
it is a path to violence to virality
so there's this guy who's going viral
now with a bunch of videos where he just
like looks at the camera all angry and
furled and he's like it is a violation
of federal law to commit perjury merrick
garland what and and the right makes him
go viral conservatives start posting
like ha ha look at this guy and it's
working
so this dude is getting made fun of
the left then sees that and they're like
we're going to prop this guy up because
the right's targeting him and he's
calling for the arrest of people we
don't like
what's going to happen in 10 or 15 years
when politics is all just reality tv
it is going to be worse than idiocracy
you think president camacho was bad
camacho was a good dude you guys you've
seen india yeah he was camacho might
have been done shout out to terry crews
he was a good if you watch idiocracy he
was actually trying to help people he
was a nice guy and he was he was just
not smart now we're gonna have something
worse
donald trump was the beginning of
reality tv politics you are going to see
it be the most insane
youtube drama tick tock drama
politics you've ever seen
and then people are going to start
punching each other in the face i
remember the youtube cnn debates in 2008
we talked a lot about in in videos
internet youtube videos at the time like
hey guys we have the technology let's
interact with our public officials now
let's have like a virtual let's do this
for real and let the world see and so
cnn got involved all of a sudden now
cnn's curating what questions get asked
so you know i send a question about the
federal reserve to barack obama because
i want to hear what he thinks about it
for real and they don't use that
question they use questions like real
real surface level and you know a nice
reality tv twist to politics that was
like the beginning and then of course
trump got elected in 2016. and what's
the biggest problem one of the biggest
problems i'm seeing is when you get into
congress you become famous and then your
twitter account goes huge forever that's
not true they all know who every every
congress person that i've have heard
their name i go to twitter they have a
million a million or more subscribers
because you've heard their name yeah
every musician i've heard of has so many
followers they can leave congress and
now they're famous and they can get a
book deal and have followers how many
how many members of congress are there
400 and something 435 435 right yep um
can you name 20 of them probably if you
give me some time are you a fan of
congress name 20 of them
that's what's up 20 congressmen to be
allowed obviously we all know who
alexandria ocasio-cortez is
but
the rank and file members sure sir i
said name a member of congress from uh
iowa
oh i can't one of them just endorsed my
campaign marionette miller meeks oh he
knows it yep i worked at the house
republican super pac before this so
iowa's congressional delegation is uh
marinette miller meeks
cindy axne the lone democrat ashley
henson and randy feenstra cindy
accidentally is the lone democrat
representing the state of iowa her
office in des moines is completely
closed to her constituents just
as i reported at the free beacon but yes
uh those are the four members of
congress from iowa thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you